men don't need women for a relationship
either we don't need each other today
the whole reason people paired up back
in the day was for survival right but we
live in a modernized society now where
we don't need each other for survival
right it's not like oh like you said if
a burglar comes in you're calling the
police right and all of this so men need
women
actually I have a question I have a
question what what does a guy get from a
woman that he couldn't get from a cook a
cleaner and a hooker
you're right probably in if it's just a
woman with relationship definitely it
would be loyalty and the stability of
that woman your cook couldn't believe
she might say oh she needs all of those
people there's no it would be the
stability and the Loyalty definitely
right I'm not saying any that that's not
wrong right and that's but that goes
back to like why it's better to date
girls with lower body counts because
they're more loyal
yeah but that's I don't I don't know
about all of that so if a girl if a
girl's if a girl's a virgin if a girl's
a virgin on her wedding night she has an
80 chance of a happy marriage if she
sleeps with more than five people it
drops down to 30 but that doesn't mean
the man's gonna stay though how many men
women women leave most of the time it's
70 to 80. if you're college educated
it's 90 and they cheat at similar rates
and there's actually studies that have
come out recently saying that women
cheat more than men because think about
it we have way more opportunity we walk
down the street say hello to a man he's
down women
as a woman's choice to be single and
it's a man's choice to be in a
relationship 100 right however if a man
cheats yes this is that's like maybe
that the females obviously cheat more
Society is changing things are changing
women want to show that we're the
masculine ones which is why we're
demasculating the man who cares yeah but
what you're talking about what I'm
saying like what is that why are you
giving them an excuse it's not an excuse
it's not an excuse it's that it's facts
in my opinion so if women want to become
this way but I'm saying you just said
you said a statement you said that like
men are the ones cheating and I said no
recent Studies have said that women are
the ones cheating and now you're
changing the subject no but I'm talking
about specifically if for example a
virgin she doesn't know any much
different depending on her life
and I'm saying that doesn't mean they'll
have a happy marriage going back to your
specific point which is why I point out
men cheat I'm not saying that every
single one but I think like as adults
but I'm saying it like as adults in a
conversation like yes there are going to
be exceptions but if you have an 80
chance isn't that better than a 30
chance and if you were a dude you pick
the you pick the the 80 chance and
second off the other problem is like a
lot of times what girls will do is
they'll give it to the last guys for
free and then try to like or use Honda
Civic and trying to require BMW prices
but you can't go back to being a new BMW
I do agree after a certain period of
time sex means nothing to people like
sex doesn't mean anything it's not
valued I do agree but that's why I
mentioned earlier if a woman is going to
be valued to be quoted she needs to be
like she can't just be accessible to
anyone you have to have a high-pressed
value on yourself 100 in this Society
because things are not the same you know
the funny thing is
it's 14 of her girls are virgins at the
age of 25 if you're wondering okay I
want to go back to something you said
earlier so you said
um
men men need women and women don't need
men earlier you were talking you're
aware when Pearl was asking us about
Kevin Samuels and courting you had said
oh yes I do think women should be
courted because I want a man to buy me
nice things a man to treat me like this
but if you don't if men don't need if
women don't need men then why would you
need a man so there's a big difference
between need and wants I don't need a
dude but yeah I would want somebody to
buy things that I don't want to buy for
myself definitely and um well you know
you know why don't you want to buy it
for yourself like I well
why do you want someone where's the
desire to develop that you actually want
someone to buy for something for you
though if you can get it for yourself
just it's not just buying things that's
really superficial it's not just buying
things like but there's there's a
difference between wanting a partner and
needing a partner and most women want to
partner for various different reasons
like to be bought things but that's to
be four things yeah to to have somebody
to cuddle at night to have somebody to
talk to to have somebody to build things
with and men don't need them
no no no but men need women men need
women to build legacies men need women
to have stable Partnerships with men
need women to have sex with women
that cannot be without them okay if
that's if that's true if what you're
meant if what if what you're if what
you're saying is correct then why did
only 40 of men reproduce historically
and eighty percent of women and dead
wait so I'm saying I 40 percent of men
reproduce historically 80 percent of
women dead so who needs who more because
men historically more men have lived
without women than women have lived
without men yeah not in my own in not in
my world so yeah but your world is not
really close to reality yeah but
can anybody hear my mic yeah look alive
this has all sounded like it's in your
world yeah
that's fine I want to ask you a question
going back to what you said previously
so you said every single woman deserves
to be coated yeah then you also said
that if a man and a woman want a date
and have sex which is different they can
right do you believe dating can lead to
a relationship and sustainability yeah
so why the [__] a man cooling if you
can [__] you and date you and then get
into a relationship long term anyway
well I think it's part of a man like
putting in the effort that needs to be
put in but he can do that he can do that
don't need to just coach it with sex
we've established that so if a man can
date you yeah by a courtship and have
sex and can lead to a relationship why
is a man gonna spend all of his emotion
time and resources to me as a woman
right so for me as a woman literally
only 50 of women
woman hasn't right it's for men
orgasms yeah it's like he asked you he
asked you one question because I'm
getting back to his question because
okay for me as a woman I'm not going to
just start dating and sleeping with a
guy because one like the sex on my half
is more for you more for than guy than
it is for the woman you're definitely
going to come I might not I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry I do yes I do I'm sorry
I understand on a personal level that's
how you feel but the truth in America is
overall that's irrelevant get back to
the question I said if a man gives
that's what you said I'm going back on
your statement right if a man can date
you right he have sex and caught you
separate to just courtship which I'm
telling you because why am I gonna just
be having sex with you when it could not
when it might not go anywhere and then
you're gonna complain on the other hand
that oh your body count is high I don't
want you why am I gonna right but the
point is that could happen you're
looking at it from a woman's point of
view yeah salmon right yeah but like the
problem is you don't look at things from
Men's point of view I don't want to I
don't need to I know so how are you
that's that's like I think that's the
first thing I think I think in your
world two plus two is five I understand
that you have like infinite value based
on infinite things I'm gonna I'm gonna
read um a hundred dollar super chats
guys I read faster so I'm just yeah okay
but traditionalism is valued in women
because it shows how she values herself
and her body if you indiscriminately
give your body away to everyone it's not
special anymore what makes anyone think
a hoe would make moral or sound choices
for their man and their kids or not
divorce him that's true can I ask you a
question wait so if that's true then why
would he Corner no but then as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible